what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today is episode
7 of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and
you guys already know if you have
watched three or more of my lives and
you do not subscribe what do we have
speaking of beef you guys can get your
we got beef merch like if you go below
this video in the comments um also
before i start we have a stream sponsor
today which is cooking with chris if you
guys want customized meal plans i'm down
10 pounds in a month okay this is how
good this meal plan is haven't i've been
playing better last month
yeah yeah i'm freaking beast i'm i'm
telling you the last month i have seen
like this is the best i've ever felt in
my life so if you guys
want to get on that buy his meal plan i
swear to god it's worth the money okay
so to start i'm going to introduce every
guest well you guys are going to
introduce yourselves
um so say your name your age your
relationship status and where you're
from okay that's a lot i'm tiana i'm
from wolverhampton i'm 20 wells
i don't think there's nothing
i'm single
my name is reese i'm single i'm 22 and
i'm from london
i'm jessica i'm 23 and basically taking
it's looking a little basically
a little scared but
i'm eileen uh 24
24
and once again complicated
it's okay
um okay so the first question i have for
you guys today and this is for the
ladies only okay
she said no not you
do you guys um
would you guys rather work or be a
housewife
personally i would love a house hubby
really
um
i don't know i just i would love to have
like a big like career you know okay
yeah do you okay so what about when you
do you want kids
that i'm on the fence about okay i'm not
sure that makes sense
um
i mean i do want kids
but
every day that passes by it's looking
rougher and rougher i'm not gonna lie to
you
but i mean i want to be a housewife for
like the first few years of like my
kid's life at least like my first child
because like i watched my stepmom do it
with my sister and i feel like it was
like it's a good thing like you know
like you get to be with your child and
like really raise them up and like have
a good bond with them instead of relying
on someone else completely to like take
care of them so i would do that and then
like jump back into my career if
anything
yeah i think i kind of agree with you
there like when they're first born i
wouldn't want to go like straight back
to work like personally i want to be
there like that stage won't be that
stage again so their stay a toddler
like how many months or so and then they
grow up so i'd want to be there for that
yeah but yeah
no i agree i would much rather
like be home the last first couple years
if i could if i could like i don't know
if that's in the cards right
i mean like
dad was like totally okay with being the
main provider in the house okay like he
told my stepmom like no it's okay stay
home for like the first like
six years at least in like my sister's
life and that's exactly what she did and
then she got her career going and she's
making bank she did her master's during
that too so like she was able to juggle
housework easily yeah at school you know
so she did it
i honestly look up to her for that so i
definitely would probably follow in her
footsteps do you guys think being a
housewife is a full-time job
definitely yeah yeah
take out the kids clean the house cook
dinner do laundry
do shopping like what
yeah no i think it is too i think that
housewives don't get enough credit
actually
yeah like i think i've watched my
stepmom slave okay yeah
is she working
well i think it's kind of like any job
like you can do it and be lazy like you
can have the house be completely messy
and you know not you know like work at
work
yeah like you know
yeah i'll leave it to someone else yeah
yeah yeah it's like the same thing yeah
but so you guys all absolutely want kids
in the future like yeah what happened
i'll be honest like initially like
obviously when i was like 18 i was just
like yeah get married at like 26 27
kids by like 30 but now like marriage is
looking 30-ish right now
the kids are coming later too
only because i just want to make sure
that i'm fully good to go like when i
finish this masters and i get my career
going like i'm ready yeah you're happy
where you are exactly like i want to be
as stable as possible before i have kids
because i do not want to bring them into
a world where i am not mentally there
yeah that's really responsible yeah yeah
i want
i want a lot of kids i like basketball
that makes sense because like you grew
up in like a huge family yeah yeah it's
great like i don't even
need friends
like christmas i was like
no but seriously like if i get i just
it's nice knowing that i always have my
siblings and if one annoys me i got like
10 others
to
pick around
[Laughter]
you guys are all watching this
they don't they don't watch my show i'm
like what the guys
oh my god so how many kids was that did
you want i don't know i want well i need
two i can't i can't do an only child
um
so
i think four or five is a good number if
i can't okay well it depends what you
can afford right
so
um you know that might not be in the
cards but if i could afford it i'd
probably want four or five kids i got
that
see i'm trying to go past three
obviously
um
maybe if i am filthy rich
why not five six you want them but i got
them but
right now i was looking very three and
under but i definitely don't want just
one kid i don't want my kids to like
grow up an only child the same way i was
because i grew up an only child up until
i was 12. then my sister came out of
nowhere
and then when i hit 19 my brother came
out of nowhere so now like my brother's
like turning four at the end of this
month and i'm like i don't want such a
big gap with my siblings because you
know i'm not going to be able to be
there to like really create a bond with
them i have a bond with my sister for
sure but like she's still a little kid i
can't be like
my boyfriend broke up with me
yeah you know i'm going to talk to her
about that she'll just be like so today
i got a new lego scene
i don't know what you're crying about
but anyway
yeah i have a 10 year age gap with my
youngest sister so i kind of understand
that yeah
it's rough
do you feel like um like an auntie to
your younger siblings
i feel like a mother to her sometimes
bro
um when so question for you
when do you want to get married and have
kids
i was talking about you were talking
about this yesterday i don't know about
the married part um
the kid's part yeah you want like a
family well he wants a baby mama no no
no no no no he's not gonna put a ring on
it
oh no oh my gosh
what do you guys think about marriage
like i don't sorry because this might
need to be
um
i don't need to sign a piece of paper to
tell you i love you
i do think marriage is a little trivial
but i also think it's such a sweet
gesture like i don't know yeah then
let's go
to the damn life let's go out like and
then i do feel like maybe because our
society is changing to be a little more
individualistic we don't really care
about marriage as much because before
like marriage was like okay i need this
for benefits like
especially as a woman it's like i can't
have a back bank account on my own so
help me out buddy like but that's a
different like we could do [ __ ] on our
own you know like we don't have to have
a piece of paper bound to us and god
forbid if we get divorced
all that money going into divorce too
god damn like that's a lot you know but
i do like the idea of marriage just
because i think it's so beautiful to
have like two families and all together
your friends all your loved ones i think
it's better for families yeah like if
you're like you don't think there's a
difference between saying my parents are
married and like they're not like i
understand maybe between the two of you
but you don't even think for the kids no
she'll tell you why why because you said
you see how you said what did you say
you said the families right like yeah
having the families together that's that
you think that's sweet cool
you don't need to sign the paper to so
it's like it's like us on this table
right now yeah let's say
after this podcast you become the
bestest of friends do we need to sign a
paper to say that we like we we like
each other no because if we are best
friends eventually i'm your mum
only your mum i'm gonna be your mom i'm
your mom right yeah
do i need to sign a contract with my mom
too
no but i think when it comes to marriage
what it is is that it shows like true
commitment to the person because
realistically you could be with someone
for 10 15 years and still up and leave
whenever you want
yeah you can do the same thing in
marriage in the back of your mind like
could this person leave me you can do
the same thing in marriage
you can just be like you know what
i want a divorce easy right like if you
sit there and say i want to get married
like you want to be in it for life then
like you're basically saying like i'm
here till the end you know so i think
it's just the comfort that marriage
brings this changes
don't you think that's you not like not
you personally but don't you think
that's the person not trusting
themselves
hey bro that's not my problem i ain't
gonna have that problem
that's my point like you should be able
to trust yourself enough that you this
person that you're with you ain't going
to go elsewhere yeah and then you should
trust the person enough like because if
you didn't even have that choice in the
first place this marriage thing you're
talking about married to people that
have bought like like ted bundy had a
girlfriend
you don't know who ted bundy you don't
know i live underneath the roof it's
such an american staple yeah a staple
i don't know
but like no because like everyone
romanticizes it because they make so
many documentaries and movies off of him
and it's like bro we know what he did
yeah we don't have to make another movie
about him yeah well the so here's my
thing with marriage like i i think on
one hand it protects the woman to be
honest because if like you're going to
be you're the one bearing the kids
you're giving him a child you don't
think you should have any legal
protection
that's a good point that is a good point
you're going to stay at home with like
no pension because you're not going to
work right yeah
but on the other hand i do think they've
gone a little bit too far like i don't
and so i do understand
men's point of view because i don't
think the justice system treats like men
that's the all men by the way like
because even my friends like they want
to get married i'm thinking i say to
them [ __ ] that like
i ain't doing that [ __ ] like
and the woman i'm with she she better
know like listen
i'm going to treat you like you're like
we're married yeah and you're gonna feel
like we're married you're like i don't
need to put no ring in your finger to me
it's for you to like it's like mother's
day i don't believe in mother's day why
do i need a day to tell my mom i love
her that's that what is it i know i do
agree with mother's day the mother's day
coming but i feel like it's just like a
gesture you know it's just like a
mother's day especially it's just like a
day dedicated to all mothers and it's
not like oh like it's the only day i'm
gonna tell you i love you it's just a
day dedicated for them because to give
them a little bit and then like back
with marriage i feel like
it's not that they people need the piece
of paper to like show that they trust
you or like that you commit i feel like
it's just
something that they have kind of for
themselves because they want to be
married to that other person it's like
an ultimate act of love yeah i think
it's like a tradition as well you got to
keep that in mind like christmas is not
always about like jesus
sometimes it's just about the moment you
know
yeah
exactly
what if you fell in love with a girl
this is your dream girl okay everything
you could ever want she says she says
look it hits all the points yeah like
yeah i would spend the rest of my life
with you but i'm not doing it without a
prank
you say
oh
god damn what makes people so against it
it's not it's not that i'm against it
yeah it seems like you weren't because
like you decided to say no
okay you know what get your dream girl
like i mean
there's seven billion people how hard
that is to
i don't care like i don't care about
that like it's like you if you if you're
marrying a person you mind that person
because of the person is who they are
before me like that you ain't marrying
them because
they look nice you understand but don't
get twisted the attraction comes first
but after the attraction you gotta find
some some sort of nose yeah i was just
out here
it wasn't just looks right so she has
all the other qualities you look for
whatever i want to communicate all right
all right okay okay okay you know what
what comes to our compromise
like let me show you how like
we can have this we can have the we can
have the ceremony but we ain't like i
ain't signing no papers would you do a
compromise of a prenup or something like
that
no no
like why are you so worried about the
ring or about signing papers like i
ain't worried about no ring okay so
there's no
question i'm gonna ask you this are your
parents married no okay were they ever
married and divorced no
is that why you feel that way no i don't
even look at it like that don't know
your parents want to like yeah i don't
even pay attention like dude yeah
okay yeah like they they haven't been
together like
i think since i've bought since i was
born
literally so like don't get twisted i
know them both but like
this is how i am like i don't look at my
mom and think oh
that's the type of woman i want like i'm
my own
i'm my own person like
have you ever like grown up seeing any
like stable marriages yeah yeah yeah 100
100 so what shied you away from that
what it's not about that it's not about
me it's not about me seeing them and
being shy it's about like what you know
i'm based off of what what like today
yeah i am basing it off of like but like
what today is making you think that then
cool
you girls yeah i knew he was gonna make
a massage
not all of you not all of you yeah but i
feel like girls are evil
like oh
where did that come from
let the man talk yeah
as i said not all of you like i've
yeah i think of the evil man like i
think you know um
will
fully go for like bro there's been
stories like you know like there's been
stories where
yeah there has their house their house
tell me the story my experience
actually let them talk let them talk
sorry
all right
so you don't want me to tell you my
story specifically that i'm talking
about
okay
um
how do you even explain it cool i've
i've
been with i've met
i'm talking to a girl yeah
we've been talking for a while yeah
and
like
and when i say a while
like two three months that's not a while
but we took it for a while it felt like
a while anyway
we're talking talking talking i've taken
her out this place that place the other
place
and
literally
like she was the whole time i was taking
her out
she was [ __ ] uh one of my friends
yeah and bear in mind like i would like
i'm speaking to her i'm telling her the
truth like i'm not
like um hiding and i'm like bro like
you're fine if you're on it like i'm on
it too if you want to be my girl then
i'm like i'm saying all of this like
i've been very transparent okay and if
she's doing that
but do you think do you think that like
that you should
think women are evil just because the
girl screwed you over one time okay
okay and you know there's gonna be and i
know you could probably think of other
stories
i don't think girls are held accountable
to the same standard men are that's a
whole different conversation but
but like how are you going to judge an
entire group of people based on a couple
bad things no okay it's not a couple bad
things because i like okay it's not just
me i got boys yeah and i have it's not
just my stories it's my boy stories too
right
now
like men also do the same to women so
you can definitely but
yeah definitely you see you see manya
like
cool this might
go above topic but you see man where i i
believe uh we're actually nurturing
people we're healing people we are like
emotional people at heart right
at heart don't come out yeah is that no
no you're right it doesn't like it
doesn't come out and it's like because i
like not to get into it but like society
and all these things just don't come out
cool like we're genuinely
like
nurturers yeah
so that you you get when we
get hurt by a girl but like you know
[ __ ] this like like why am i doing
all of these things all of these things
that because
impress a girl and she don't like it
like you heard girls don't go for the
nice guy the nice guy
like you said yesterday like
the girls say they want a nice guy the
guy decides to be nice and they don't
want him and it's like what the [ __ ]
like you said you wanted this i'm this
and you like
you don't want it
i don't know where you're getting your
girls from but
i'm sorry no you don't have to say that
it's kind of like the way you talk it's
almost out of like a fear mindset yeah
like you're like oh i'm afraid of
divorce or i'm afraid she might do
something so i'm just not going to do it
at all
oh i'm not
so if you trust in your partner exactly
why wouldn't you mind getting married
then
because for me it's not about like trust
or not it's like bro
it's a piece of paper like bear in mind
i haven't said anything about just a
piece of paper
right i hate you
i mean
no it's not that big of a deal then i
hear you but it's like why do i need to
go through that like for a reason
like because because the girl you love
wants it
do you know what
you're making him like short circuit
right now no no no are you scared that
if you give in that that girl will break
your heart
um oh my god we're giving him a fairy
session
we're making him realize a lot of [ __ ]
right now um i'm not gonna let like i
don't
like
i don't explain this like i don't
that's a very good question um
yes or no
yeah because sometimes i'm scared that i
might break her heart no i mean like i
don't like
sometimes i might not even trust myself
if you're like listen i like you but i
gotta sort my own [ __ ] out so i can
actually be with you because like and
more time sometimes
you might meet the right person but at
the right at the wrong time so it's like
i haven't got my [ __ ] together yet so
in order for me to be of you i have to
have my [ __ ] together and i don't know
how long you're gonna you're gonna be
here so i might keep her around for a
little bit and like but i know i want to
get my [ __ ] together with the right
person and wrong time i feel like that's
not really a real thing i feel like if
it was the right person that would be
the right time someone just be just
wrong person in general
household i don't think it's true
because like because i really don't
believe that you grow up
you might meet someone as a kid and
that's the wrong person because i think
i think the biggest like right person
wrong time is between men and women
because i think women
are looking for more serious stuff like
sooner than men are
that makes sense and so i could see like
the right person wrong time like
especially in the space i'm in they
always talk about men not getting
married till their mid-30s and women
like earlier is what they suggest
um
now
you know do people do that i don't know
but
but that's like but i could see it in
that sense like if i fell in love with
someone that was like younger than me
you know it would be like like i'd
probably be looking for something more
serious than they would yeah yeah i mean
that's true i feel like it always just
depends on the situation you can't
really do much about it like
i feel like um i struggle with like my
relationship as it is just because i
live so [ __ ] far now like it's tiring
yeah and like we have to like you know
have an open relationship and like stuff
like that
um
but you know like we're willing to
get through all this [ __ ] so that it's
fun down the line later you know like
when i come back and all that actually
what do you think about that as a guy's
point of view
open relationship no no right person
wrong time
right person
no my people's ready to say something no
one of my best friend
my best friend is in a real open
relationship but
um
what do i think sorry what was your
question again sir like just from a
guy's point of view do you think right
person you think you do think right
person wrong time is a thing yeah yeah
yeah 100 would you say wow i've gone
through that even like when i was 18 19
remember i told you like the last time
that i was here i was in like the most
toxic relationship yeah and um
me and my ex were just so immature
and like barking at each other all the
time like we had serious issues but he
was like my best friend like i mean this
was the dude i was willing to die for
you know yeah and like now we're good
now because like we matured so much and
we move past it so now we're friends
like we're actually cool but you know
like had none of that happened we
probably have a relationship now for all
that note you know like we might be cool
because we we're we finally grew up
but back then it just was not the time
at all so do you think that stops like
that expires wrong person like the right
person wrong time after like 25 like
that's another thing
everybody matures at a different rate
i think men just like a lot of them
want to wait on that stuff too late
because i kind of see my brother and
[Applause]
and i feel like he loves her and i think
he wants to spend the rest of her life
with her but i could feel it more from
her
like oh i want to get married sooner
rather than later yeah and he's more
like i'll do it when she makes me you
know what do you know what you know what
i think and i'm going to be so honest
i'm going to be so i'm going to be sorry
i'm going to say something
yeah um
i think we're like no because let me
explore my options a little bit more
and then like when i've exhausted my
options then i'm gonna be like cool you
does that make sense same thing that
guys do so it's like the first person
okay after that phase is done it's like
the first person that meets those like
first person that will marry you you did
accept but like when you're initially
dating it's like okay i'm gonna be
really choosy and picky and then after
i've gone through that phase of like
meeting loads of women now i want to
settle down okay you're the first person
i dated no no no no so let's say you've
already met a girl and you and her
already on a vibe yeah okay
you know i quite like this girl okay but
you ain't even trying to tell her that
you just like you just keep on hurting
you don't want to have your phone yeah
exactly you're just keeping her
okay i could potentially marry this girl
in the future but right now i need to
live longer yeah but i don't think that
right now if it ends i'll be so honest
with you i don't like right now i don't
i don't think it happens but like it
depends on the guy and it depends on how
you think because
do you think that many guys go for this
place okay like oh i need to explore my
options before i settle down
yeah i think all guys
have this explore i think everybody has
it
i feel like everybody has it yeah
like i think more so men yeah i feel
like it's more common to see to men
because i feel like girls we're a little
quicker to get into a relationship i
feel like you know a secret too because
there's always that like
um stereotype about us being like what
are we and he's like
we are farmers
did you think we were together oh i'm
sorry i only took you on dates for six
months
my mother slept with that lady
that's so weird
but
yeah it's definitely a little more
common to see that in guys where they're
like i think like now especially in the
world that we live in it's a lot harder
to commit because we're always thinking
about our options right like we got like
tinder at the palm of our hands bro so i
don't i got blocks
why i don't know it's still a mystery so
i'm blocked and like
i got a question if you look would you
guys rather meet your
husband guy mate whatever you want to
call it
um on tinder in person i don't think it
matters it doesn't matter for me and one
of my best relationships is off of
bumble so like yeah my one of my best
was off tinder so i don't think in
person how do you yeah like how do you
guys gauge the personality and the whole
like everything online like i don't get
i believe you've got to meet them as
soon as possible so like arrange a day
and then it's not really about like what
you're talking about it's about the date
so you think you go and meet him as soon
as possible what if the motherfucker's a
psycho then you just you find out
you don't know but you can go you're
gonna know that because you guys
in public you wouldn't know either yeah
no no but what time is that
girls are very careful about setting up
these dates because we know that there
are psychos out there yeah like send
your location that kind of stuff like if
you make the arrangement as soon as
possible then you'll meet the person as
soon as possible like in person so
what's the safety net what's like what
what are you guys what's the safety net
what's like all right
like cool you said you said you said not
on dates but it's never it's
like i i've never it doesn't get further
than that one date yeah no because it's
like that's rough well no i've gone on
i'm trying to think because it's been a
while since i really
yeah dating apps have never really
because mostly because i get too nervous
so after like the first day i'm like
this guy could be crazy i don't know and
i just kind of psyched myself out
sometimes yeah i think it's because in a
foreign country because i find like when
i was living abroad that like in a
farmhouse is a bit different you can't
just like oh mom pick me up that kind of
thing you feel like you don't have that
safety net of people
no because i lived in a city i didn't
really know many people in before
um
i don't know i've moved around a lot
i don't know i just got like anxiety
from like the awkwardness of the first
date and like first meeting them too and
then
but like i wouldn't say like that's just
like only off of like online because
i've only done like maybe like one
or two online things and i was just like
never again but like i've even like met
a person that like met someone at a bar
or whatever i was like okay like he
asked me today i was like cool he's like
he seemed like a cool lot he ended up
being a freaking psycho what do you do
he was so we were like hang out and then
like i guess it was my mistake i was
like oh like he's like do you want to
get a drink at my place i'm like sure
but i was like okay nothing's gonna
happen
and like i got there and he like tried
to make a move on me i was like i'm
sorry but like no and then he ended up
getting like pissed i
hate it when guys get mad when you won't
sleep with them i'm like i'm not a
hooker
in your apartment no it is it was like
that's even worse like because that's
not your own turf you know you you don't
know what to do in that point like do i
hate you
this guy older than you um i think just
like a couple years but i was just
thankful that his like roommates were
there so like i wasn't the only one you
know and i was just like i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here
i literally ran out the door
that's mad
[Music]
all the serial killers they're always
like you're at the bar and they fell in
love at first sight little did shirley
know he was gonna get murdered that
night like
you know did i just rhyme you did ryan
you did you did boss
you know it's funny i'm banned from
tinder too
this is a really long time ago when i
was trying to catfish guys on you
it's for a youtube video
no no in college i had this idea of a
dating app okay so i was going to start
a dating app i was going to call it
roster talk
and it was going to be is going to be i
felt like athletes like like dating
athletes so you had to be on a team to
get on that dating app and so you could
swipe on like division one players
division two division three and like you
could swipe on you could pick a school
in your conference and like swipe on
away teams home teams because i felt
like
yeah like like half the reason like guys
would come to our games like the other
teams is because they wanted to like
talk to girls from our team or the other
teams
i just felt like that was like a thing
so what i did was i went on tinder
um and i was trying to gather market
research for if there was any money in
this app so i went to schools in the
conference and i surveyed people and i
was like take my survey just asking like
would you be interested in app like this
stuff like that and i was like you know
what it would be easier i think go on a
dating app and guys in jerseys
on the app i'm gonna send them the
survey
so
you got caught yeah well i think they
thought i was like a bot cause i was
saying oh will you take my survey here's
the link
yeah so i got like bamboos
i think
well it's just a lot of work
back to the original question do women
still want to work
my answer to the question it's not the
first couple years i've kissed i don't
if i if i could not but i'm not
expecting that you know it depends how
much i don't know i just don't want to
like put my career on hold
or like put what i'm doing on hold for i
mean like obviously if i do have kids
i'll love them and i'll still like spend
time with them but i don't want to like
absolutely pause everything i'm doing
and then like just spend only time with
them you know what i mean do you do you
feel like you'll be fulfilled like at 50
if you i mean you have a career yeah and
like what do you want to do uh i also do
like biomedical research okay so you
have a really successful research career
you have that whole thing
but then you're alone at christmas
because you have no family
like immediate family do you feel like
you'd be like fulfilled with that i mean
you know i'm around friends and family
maybe not
like i mean
yeah
i
i
like i love christmas or whatever but i
just
i'm not like huge on like celebrating
either i don't know so i feel like
i don't know actually maybe when i'm
older i'll feel differently yeah because
like i'll be maybe valuing different
things than i am right now well it's
funny because they talk about in the
space of youtube i'm in where girls
because you're 23
24 okay when they get to like their late
20s early 30s that's when they a lot of
girls change their mind
about
like kids
so it'll be interesting to see i mean
like i used to want like always too
but like now i'm just like i don't know
if i want them but if i do then i want a
lot of them can i ask you a question
yeah what type of guy do you want
because if you if you um wanna
you wanna you want a house husband a
house hug well i mean not like
the house hobby i mean like
you know just like someone like i don't
want to be the one staying home and
taking care of the kids that's all
you know said them kids go see you when
later
i'm kidding
like i i mean
maybe not exactly a house it's like
someone that would do like the 50 50
work with me so like i'm not the only
one doing everything you know
i feel like um like our generation
especially was like raised on
it was like dependent on the mother
raising the kids and i would love to see
like a 50 50 on the mother and the
father
see that's funny because it was like the
total opposite for me oh really like my
dad is my main provider like my mom
she's a little rough
you know because they they divorced when
i was really young you know um but my
dad was always like my number one like
he was always the person getting me the
clothes necessary doing my laundry
cooking me food like everything that
needed to be done he was doing it yeah
you know and my mom was kind of like the
opposite instead i was taking care of
myself whenever i stayed at her house
you know
so
i feel like i get i get you i definitely
get you i definitely want like someone
if i were to marry a man to do to be the
same way that my dad was you know like
as involved with the kids as i am at the
very least you know and if i have to put
in more work towards my career then he's
willing to step back and you know take
the reigns for a bit when it comes to
the kids
so and i would do the same back of
course if he has like his own um
goals career then yeah his own
aspirations as well you know you know
what's crazy
one of
you guys say this but like the data
doesn't match up with what you say which
is kind of nuts wait what
like
do you know do you know what the number
one reason like like the number one
indicator that you're gonna get divorced
is
the woman starts out earning the man
that sounds like a personal issue
and i like women so
i like women too so
and lucky for me
but they leave 80 of the time 90 if
you're college educated so if you guys
get divorced 90 of the time it'll be
your choice
is that crazy yeah
so but at least i know i have the wings
sorry go ahead is it like the woman that
leaves them yeah women leave men don't
so when they start out earning the man
then they leave yeah statistically
but do you think like it's because
like
it's gotta be a combination it's gotta
be more than just like that not earning
enough it's gonna be like maybe they
don't have enough aspirations or goals
to like you know i think that's exactly
what it is they don't have enough
aspirations and goals so they're not
making more money i don't want to be
with somebody like that male or female
yeah you know yeah um i would want
somebody who has just as many goals and
aspirations as i do because do you try
to get to the top with my person you
know do you do you think that though if
you made a commitment to be with that
person for life that you should honor it
even if like maybe they're not acting
the way you want at the time
i mean you know if we have a really good
relationship at the end of the day it's
not the end of the world if they don't
necessarily have the same viewpoint yeah
i do yeah when it comes to like work you
know because
not everybody wants to work for life not
everybody wants to yeah
yeah absolutely
so you know if we have great
communication
you know um just a great connection in
general like we we see a lot of things
on the same page
i don't think it's going to ruin the
relationship you know i think i think
it's hard for
like i think as women like we want
a guy that's more driven than us like
typically
or maybe like just as driven and
hardworking
i feel like
from what you're saying like if we're
like out earning them maybe it seems
like
we feel like we're doing less the work
going on here and i think um
a lot of the like i feel like a lot of
people like break up because one person
feels like they're putting in more work
than the other
and i feel like if that ever gets off
balance maybe that's the reason why the
other leaves mm-hmm
what's hard work to you guys because i
like i don't know about you but i know
you look i watch you lot play um
volleyball sometimes
um
you guys look like you train you you
train for this [ __ ] and you like you do
it
um so hard work to you guys like for
instance like an athlete like let's be
real most people don't um
appreciate
what is to be athlete yeah yeah they
don't appreciate exactly they don't
appreciate ways to be athlete and you
guys understand
it's a lot of work it's a lot of work do
you think it's an athlete you'd have to
date another athlete
um
no no necessarily i don't think um but
you know that's funny because i've
actually never dated someone that's not
an athlete
i think
um i would say it's or determination or
drive or do whatever you want to call it
it's just like driven like doing stuff
so i don't i don't i've always said i
don't necessarily care about money so i
would marry um i always use the example
of a coach because i don't think coaches
make a ton of money typically or artists
whatever
but it's just someone that's working
every day towards something and that's
just like
bumming out basically yeah what's
bombing
yeah and then it's like
you've been talking about this for
months yeah like it doesn't have to be
quite earning specifically but if
they're like showing that they're
working hard on whatever they're doing
or just a defeatist mindset is really
unattractive like there's always
what mindset it's like a defeatist
attitude like like already thinking that
they can't change their situation or
make things better yeah because there's
just this obstacle in this one this one
this one yeah don't get me wrong they
find excuses there's a million obstacles
i i know some people have it easier than
others but it's just like okay what now
you can't you can't change that yeah
it's just like what are you gonna do
about it like if you really want
something you're gonna go after it no
matter what yeah i genuinely feel that
and if the universe keeps sending you
signals that it's not for you it's not
for you that's okay yeah but if you're
gonna find the littlest tiniest excuses
to just be like i can't do this it's
raining outside gosh darn it like yeah i
can't be with you like yeah it's one
thing it's like it's like yo my mom died
i gotta go back for a second yeah by all
means take the time that you need to
heal and mourn that death and do
whatever the hell why are you laughing
and smiling
no i was not just dying i was gonna say
like i think because you guys are
athletes yeah like
we all have something in common
yeah and it's like we understand
discipline and hard work yeah like we
understand it like an average i would
say like a lot of people you know aren't
that like okay exactly like we know like
for instance we like you wake up in the
morning
you might feel you might feel like [ __ ]
but you know you got training at 8 8am
so bro like as much as you might feel
like [ __ ] bro you got to get up and go
training and
when you're at training you might not
feel like [ __ ] anymore
you know so like that's why i'm saying
like
the athlete
um
idea of hard work i think art like is it
different our idea of hard work is
judgmental
does that make sense not judgmental but
it's like it's hiding everyone else
which makes us judgmental i feel like
it's just a painful way because a lot of
athletes go for endurance they do a lot
they go for a lot of pain to get to
where they are like they train a lot and
sometimes it's not easy and it's like
that mindset of being driven to the
point like sometimes it's going to hurt
a bit like they don't mind like they've
pushed themselves that level it's
different from like the average person
i'd say like i don't think every average
person would be prepared to push
themselves to like that kind of limit
and get somewhere and you know it's not
only athletes that have this mindset too
you know like people who play
instruments for example yeah those
people be spending six seven hours a day
just practicing on the same god damn
issue with the same goddamn
that's rough [ __ ] right there honestly i
genuinely um
yeah like i've been there you know
i get that but also like i when it comes
to me i'm a very well-rounded person
because i did damn near everything
growing up from dancing to instruments
to sports like you name it and i did it
so i definitely know what it means to
work hard but i can also
see a lazy person from a mile away at
the end of the day what's up what does
the ladies person look like a
[ __ ] that has no aspirations
like but you might just because you
ain't got no aspirations don't mean you
can't work hard
um
yes i do because you're blowing because
let's say this you can work at
mcdonald's right
you work at mcdonald's
and you can stay there for the rest of
your life and you got no plan to get out
of that situation if you have no plan to
move to the next step in your career or
your life well that's what i'm saying
define the define the next step like
what is the next step if their next step
is not it doesn't have to be a specific
st it's just like
look no no no you want to get it's
working towards something so it could
even be maybe the gym is his passion you
know maybe he's just trying to get jack
i don't know
maybe it's art maybe it's music but it's
just like someone else do something yes
something like they're like already
there then they're just like working to
be the best that they can be on that
thing
i especially want to see someone that's
working to not stop being the best
person that they can be just like
personally
yeah i mean like it's fine to be like
content but i mean wouldn't you rather
be like the best of what you're doing
that's a fact okay okay question
you guys want to play truth or dare
but let's go ahead so we're guys if you
have truth or dares for us super chat
them
um nothing crazy okay this is
kids watch this show i'm sure
um okay
so the way i'm gonna do it
is i have ones if you guys couldn't
think of any
i forgot what i wrote because i wrote
these a couple days ago oh geez okay
explicitly do you know the level of
intensity there's these two okay
what do you think i would do
i'd say pretty like
not
and tell them you still love them that's
what i feel like it is did you really
love your ex
okay
well if you don't want to do it
you drink for five seconds
okay for five seconds
now remember you don't have to use it
you can make one up your own
so i think the way we should do it
is um
like clockwise
oh wow
okay okay
um
so you then i would give one to you
yeah truth or dare
[Music]
i'm trying to decide if you're gonna
hate me for this one
um what's the guy that you're you're
it's complicated guy
you should call him and
is he watching now um he's actually
working right now
okay good to know
[Music]
i don't like that one
take a shot
um you know actually i'm gonna do what i
was gonna do
call him and ask him to if he'll be your
boyfriend
okay then you just call him if he
doesn't answer then you did it or take a
drink okay
he's like
okay he said god forbid if he's on this
break
yeah it's your turn
um oh wait
what
oh my god
what
i've had mic problems the whole time
that they weren't picking up
y'all why did you not tell me this
earlier oh my god it's working now but
for your mic yeah no it's fine it's fine
go ahead go ahead i fixed it
i'm just like mad at myself
okay
i don't want to be too mean because i
don't know that
she chose me she would have just whipped
my ass
okay no i can't i'll just do
this copy was oh my god i don't know
this is great
call an old boss to tell them you're in
love with them
look at the time
i've been in old past old boss so you
know i mean i lost it with my old boss
so i don't think it's appropriate no
damn
i think i'll have to drink to that one
do i leave this out
okay
okay
jessica your turn all right i'll choose
this [ __ ] right
you're not safe
um truth or dare um
you're crazy
no i swear i won't play you i swear
oh yes i will
i'm excited
i have to think of something though i'm
i'm thinking deep in the back of my mind
guess who's gonna look up a really good
truth then
no no i'd be like do you have mommy
issues
i said i'd be like do you have mommy
issues
um
just kidding
okay can i ask something that's not
necessarily he can drink he has the
opportunity to say no i know i know but
i really want to ask something that he
he can't back down on answering
okay what is the most trifling thing
you've done in a relationship oh that's
a good one
that you've ever done
the worst thing you've ever done to like
[ __ ]
i feel like you are slightly alive
everybody [ __ ] up in a relationship
that's for sure i'll tell you about that
all right
like
all right
all right this was bad as you go live
i mean it got me and my
girlfriend at the time
um
[Music]
we decided we were going to go on a
break
yeah and this break went on a little bit
too long
like it went on longer than it should
have gone on for she didn't mess it she
didn't call me bear man we we went on
break because like relationship was just
being [ __ ] and whatnot i want to ask who
who insinuated the break
she brought it to me and i was just like
yeah yeah i'm not gonna like you right
okay we ain't doing what we're supposed
to do here so um
when a break
and then um
uh i basically
just had a whole nother girlfriend
oh wow in that short space of time no no
no wait it doesn't sound like it was
short if it was saying
yeah like it sounds like this might have
gone for more than a month
that break this break went for longer
than it was supposed to
no one had contact with anyone how long
was it
do you remember how long it was um
no i don't i want to say two months but
i actually don't remember how long it
was that is long break
that's not a break that's a breakup
that's what i don't think that you
really cheated if it was like two months
break
but did you get back together yes but
you're not supposed to have like a whole
nother girlfriend either
during the break then why this is a
double-edged sword were you talking to
her during the break
like
done that kind of feeling
yeah
i feel like it's a double-edged sword
because at the end of the day you should
have communicated with her and been like
what's going on here
but at the same time i understand i
fully understand i hate feminists oh god
oh okay what happened
okay
so um
okay cool this girl was my girlfriend
but we would which one
which one
the
and then one day
my girlfriend called me and i was like
oh we're still
what's going on
we're still doing this and then
i want to go meet her and um
you know y'all did some we did what we
did oh and like basically at the end of
that like basically she
the long story short because this this
will be actually long story long story
short they ended up being on the phone
together
talking to each other and she was like
oh
oh so you got set up
i'm not sitting
like they called each other like one of
them called the other one it was like oh
like is this your man i was like oh
i'm coming to you as a woman moment
one of them was like to me oh she was
rude and then the other one was like oh
she was rude so i was like bro like i
don't know who to believe that
did they did they both still want to be
with you or are they both like nah
oh you got it like that
they both
still wanted to be with me but um but
huh i made a
terrible decision who did you pick yeah
i made a [ __ ] decision
um the girl that i wasn't with before
bear in mind
[Music]
it's not like the same one by the way
that
i said before um
like that was my girl like i don't know
how why i didn't choose all but like
that was my best friend my like that was
my
girl and um i don't know i was like you
know what i'm tired of your [ __ ]
are you are you still friends with that
girl
or she did that
yes
yeah but not because of that situation
because like after that for what
situation man what did you do
what's funny is after we like we got
back together but like when we got
together we were chilling we're cool
like so me and that girl broke up and
yeah oh my god this is messy
[Music]
and the original one got back together
yeah i said it was my girl and whatnot
and then
i'll be honest i [ __ ] up like
i'm [ __ ] up so that was what you
what'd you do with that yeah what what
how'd you [ __ ] it up
man just trying so hard not to go into
detail we just keep digging and digging
come on we're girls we're like fbi
agents everywhere right like
i don't know what you expected look at
the dog look look look over there
ain't no dog ellie's in my room
i'm careful
hey but what
okay okay but wait what so what happened
the second time
don't be shy is it more trifling than
the first time
okay so then that's so that's the story
that we wanted
that's what we were waiting for yes
if you really don't want to say it
though i was being a quote unquote
narcissist
oh
he put the quotes but he might have been
weak
so
i was being a narcissist and then
depending on what you guys think of
narcissist is um
on top of that like we i was doing the
whole
i want to build you
i don't want to be of you i want to be
of you i don't want to be you're
wishy-washy
but like i knew i wanted to be with her
but
the whole i want to be with you i don't
want to be of you was like i don't know
if
i deserve you type of thing
like as in i don't know if i'm ready to
have you so i was like you know what
let's just break up because i'm not
good enough for you how old were you at
this time
how old is that we got to go for two
years so 200 bit
um
from 19
how old are you now i'm so sorry i'm 22.
okay
um
what was your question
what did you ask
um
the story behind how you were
what like how you were a [ __ ] to her
no you are something different what was
the other one your age
like how old were you when you were
together yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i think i was a young
kid
fair enough i'm gonna pause this really
quick because we got a super chat
okay i like you paul
um
okay this is a question for everyone
did you ever deliberately wait to break
up with a significant other because
there was a trip scheduled and you
wanted to do the trip
because you had a trip scheduled with
that person and you wanted to do the
trip but you knew you didn't want to be
with them
tell after the trip unfortunately i've
never done no vacation stuff so i can't
i can't um have any input i thought this
happened to me
you've done this
yeah like me like mutual but like i feel
like it happened like
we broke up just after a vacation oh so
yeah so did you know yeah sorry so he
jumped broke up with you after we broke
up with each other but i feel like we
just waited until after the vacation
because it was like a good idea but yeah
both know you were gonna break up with
each other
i feel like it was like the last laugh
kind of thing so i feel like we kind of
knew that it was going to happen
but put your mic like go make it up more
like towards your mouth yeah there you
go okay
like so
um i figured i wasn't asking actually
sorry sorry about distracting i think
reese you're next you get to truth or
dare someone
or you can you already know it's coming
to you jessica
what's your answer
um
i'm going with truth cause i'm a little
scared of you on my whole life
all right
what's the most
he's gonna ask the same [ __ ] i knew it
um
i don't know i i don't know
i don't know because you you seem very
wild
wait
don't not that wild
personality a wild wild you seem very
wild um i just have a very eccentric
personality all right what's the wildest
thing
you've done with your
partner with my partner
it doesn't have to be like sexual
thought
[Applause]
[Music]
um like on a sexual level like i've been
on in a threesome before but like
could see an emotional level um you know
what i guess the wildest thing was
trying to do like a polyamorous
relationship
oh you want me to come closer to mike
sorry
um yeah i think i tried to do a
polyamorous relationship at some point
because i thought it was going to
help the relationship in a way this was
with that person that like me and him
were like super toxic to each other when
i was like 18 19 20. you know
um
but
he
like didn't really want to do it and i
was just like no come on like we could
just wait we could just
did you say you were in a polyamorous
relationship sorry i was
i was oh you still are no no but back
then so when you say polyamorous does
that mean like you had a third person or
part of the relationship like how does
multiple people yeah so things like more
than two it's like
so
monogamy would be like let's say you and
i were dating it's just you and me you
know we don't see it
we it's just you and me and we don't see
other people an open relationship would
be you and i are emotionally connected
yeah but we are not emotionally
connected to anybody else outside of the
relationship we're just [ __ ] other
people usually unless like other people
change their definition of that and that
would be also like non-monogamy like
having like a unicorn or whatever yeah
and polyamory would be like you are
emotionally connected to several people
and sometimes that becomes like
a group you know like three or four
people in this one relationship all
together
um
but in this case like we tried it with
this one girl
and um i guess that would be the wildest
thing that i tried i had been in it
before but it was like long distance
like it really didn't mean [ __ ] but this
time you know like me and him were
together and we got this girl into the
relationship how did that work like i'm
very interested so we try to spend time
together like equally like all together
and you guys get jealous of each other
um you know i wasn't jealous but i was
insecure at that time would you talk
[ __ ] and like you got like two people
will be like oh my god they did that to
me the other day oh no
and then she and they'd be like oh my
god she did that to me too
actually
the crazy thing was i i made it clear
from the start like it was just a trial
period i just wanted to try it i didn't
necessarily want it to be the end-all
be-all of our relationship i just wanted
to see what it would be like
because it was like well she tried to
steal my boyfriend that's the thing that
i was gonna get to that see he ended up
catching feelings for her as well
and i said like i just wanted to keep it
at like baseline just liking each other
and he ended up like feeling something
for her because like they come from very
similar backgrounds meanwhile i don't
like they both came from like low-income
communities like very rough families and
i i don't come from that so
um he wanted to like protect her and
like be a really good person to her so
he didn't want to just drop her right
away and i was like
drop that [ __ ]
you're just like um hello
you know um
at some point she started like
you know oh man this [ __ ] like if i saw
her now i still would fight her i don't
care but
um
at some point wait
i wasn't jealous but i was insecure so
she said so you were jealous at the end
right
you know like i would be i mean because
of her though yeah like i didn't feel
like she was like a better [ __ ] than me
or nothing like that
um but i was scared that he was going to
leave me regardless oh okay
um but with this situation it was
rough do you think toxic relationships
like a lot of it is the people being
afraid the other person's going to leave
each other yeah definitely why because
definitely
absolutely yeah because then you start
doing crazy [ __ ] because it's like yeah
because i think that anything out of
fear
is
toxic absolutely [ __ ] out of fear yeah i
mean because yeah once that trust is
gone in a relationship it ruins
everything
but with this chick like
you know they started getting really
comfy cozy with each other
and i started getting pushed out the
scene so instead of me being the third
person like i mean instead of me being
like the the main person i looked like
the third person
and i was like
hell no
not about to make me decide
the chicken and the bees you're not
gonna make me the side order that's not
happening so um
that we finally all got together and i
was like
we all gonna take a break
i said we're all going to take a one
week break exactly one week none of us
are going to talk to each other text
each other facebook yeah i don't give a
[ __ ]
oh my god no
this is this story is [ __ ] crazy bro
i had a um a counselor back at my last
program right and i used to talk to him
all the time about this relationship it
was already toxic like bad [ __ ] wait
wait wait wait were you in high school
no no i was in college this is my life
i just can't even imagine hearing about
this as a counselor
you're like
this week this week we added a third
okay and i think it's going well next
week oh my god this [ __ ] had to steal
my man
i had to steal little props to my
counselor from stockton university you
my brother you my bro because you listen
to everything and i feel bad for you
because if it were me in your place i
would have been [ __ ] tired he
probably didn't know what to do because
he's never heard of this kind of
relationship before yeah
he handled it really well but this is
the funny thing right yeah so that week
we all agreed like we're gonna take that
break right yeah no talking no talking
no seeing each other none of that okay i
see this man
actually um monday like because i made
that decision on sunday right
monday comes around and my boyfriend
calls me anyway during that break and
he's like i just want you to know like i
still love you i care about you dearly
like this is just a really tough
situation
i'm like okay we're breaking the rules
right now but since i am your girlfriend
of course i'm gonna be like thanks babe
oh my god yeah
i love you too
me being the dumb [ __ ] that i am
oh was he tall is he at least tall
baby oh yeah don't do that do you
listen listen um it really i didn't even
care about height either like i just
genuinely love this kid today yeah i
don't know um tuesday comes around and i
have my meeting with my counselor right
and
he asks me do you trust him
and i'm like yeah i don't know why but i
do like i really do trust him even
though like he's done so much to ruin my
[ __ ] i've done also just enough to ruin
his trust at least like yeah you know
like we're in a really rough situation
um
and he's like there's nothing wrong with
that it's okay if you trust him because
you know that's your boyfriend you love
him like
it's rough and maybe you shouldn't be in
this relationship but it's not wrong for
you to trust him i'm like okay i'm
feeling good right i walk out of that
counselor situation i go to the library
i pull out my textbooks i start studying
and my intuition kicks in
and i get
this [ __ ] in the apartment in the
back of my mind i'm like
wait a minute we always we always know
we always know right right and i'm like
why did i think that and it just keeps
playing in my head this [ __ ] is in the
apartment this [ __ ] is in the apartment
it's like a movie
yeah yeah
so i i immediately throw my laptop back
into my bag my textbooks [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] studying and i start running
to the other side of my face i'm texting
my flatmates i'm like yo i think this
[ __ ] is in the apartment
no because and they're like no no no no
it's okay jessica stop freaking out it's
okay like he's not she's not there
i'm like nah i'm not listening to y'all
i'm sorry i'm trusting my intuition this
time i pull up to his door i'm banging
on that [ __ ] i decided that my excuse
was i'm gonna go come get my stuffed
animals
that was gonna be my excuse
and um he opens the door and i'm like
let me see your room i walk into his
room and she's right on the bed she's
right there and i'm like no
[ __ ] way
no way my intuition really kicked in
like wait did did he try to stop you
when you came in he didn't he just let
me in he just straight up was open about
it he was like yeah like i [ __ ] up but
in that moment
he was still he was barking at me i was
like we were supposed to be on a break
we were supposed this we were supposed
to that and he's like well i talked to
you yesterday you didn't follow the
rules either
i'm like i didn't follow the rules
because you killed me you wanted to talk
like you're my boyfriend of course i'm
gonna listen to you like wait i'm head
over heels for you bro you didn't follow
the rules
like we were both in such a rough
situation and the worst part is that
[ __ ] was on the bed laughing the whole
time
right here
she was dying in the background in bed
she's on her phone taking snapchats of
herself
i was like this [ __ ] mascara ass beat
like i've never listened to she's i've
never been in a fight before okay but
him and i are going at it and i see her
in the corner i'm like [ __ ] you are not
innocent like you came here you don't
even live on campus like you live with
your family
so on and so forth you know i'm going
off she doesn't even she doesn't give me
no attention
um and she knew that this whole time her
plan was to take my boyfriend from me um
that's the crazy part it was really her
plan because she started treating me
like [ __ ] but treating him like a king
and i was like
nah this is wrong and i was telling him
from the start i was like she's
definitely trying to wait so then how
did she get you to agree to a like a
three a three-way relationship i was
i was like this is supposed to be like a
trial period yeah like there's no
guarantee you're gonna stay here type
[ __ ] yeah my man this is my dick
and then she said she said not for long
you see like i was okay with it being
equal on all sides genuinely yeah but
when she started making it like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] i'm taking this man like
that's what i was like uh like i'm not
doing this when did you realize that she
was trying to steal him for me it was
definitely a couple weeks beforehand
because this is around february i fully
remember it was like valentine's day and
it was near our one year anniversary at
that time like before
like i mean how much time to like before
or after you've said yes to like doing
this or like that you've invited her
into
like you and your boyfriend's thing like
wait like when she started [ __ ] when
you knew what i was doing
um
if i had to guess because this was a
long time ago if i had to guess it
probably had to be a couple weeks in
like i started noticing that the way she
treated me was not equal to the way that
she treated him and i was like um i'm
not a fan of this so i started telling
him i was like yo i don't know what's
going on but she's kind of like treating
me like a side [ __ ] and it's like
really weird and he's like no she's
probably just closed off she's probably
this and that and i'm like okay i guess
like i'll listen to you for now i've got
two questions for you what is it so
during the
the sexual stuff yo how did that go
number one number two
um
at what point did you decide all right
cool
like oh no at number two do you think
that they had a conversation together
and was like you know what we're gonna
slowly
remove her remove jessica
we did get involved all together and
they have been involved separately
before i was totally fine with it at the
time i was very comfortable with it um
but this was at the like
very beginning of this situation once
[ __ ] once she started like switching up
that's when i was like um
i don't like her no more like let's
that's what i'm talking about
when you started when you started
feeling that did you do like
like when it got to the intimate part
was you two like reluctant to even like
look at each other yeah type of thing
absolutely from my end but you still did
it right no no no like once i started
feeling like uncomfortable with the
situation i was like i can't do this
like from all ends like you and you i'm
not [ __ ] with neither of y'all i
can't do this um
and the second question was
um do you think they
they were trying to remove me no see
that's the thing
she was the only one trying to remove me
he didn't realize it at all okay so
what if he was just playing dumb yeah
that's because that's why no no he
definitely wasn't because we even talked
about it like you know a couple years
after we were like damn that situation
was really crazy and he said he looked
back and he's like i really was lost in
a [ __ ] like he was really like i
did not see that coming yeah
yeah i was tight obviously but the funny
thing about all this this is by far the
funniest point of it all was that after
that whole argument whatever i was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] drive her back home and
we gonna talk about this later
i went back to my room i screamed cried
my all my roommates are there like it's
okay
it's okay baby don't worry about it
and um
eventually i text her and i'm like what
you did was [ __ ] up like you were not
supposed to be in his apartment and you
knew that like you you've been trying to
push me out this situation this whole
time that's not right like you know that
that's my boyfriend and i've been have
been together for a year like so on and
so forth and her first statement back to
me was don't get beat up [ __ ]
i knew there was a [ __ ] in that
sentence
i knew there was
my view this girl is like
five foot one yeah
she's
you guys see me now this is not my most
built form okay
[Music]
like workout videos and she like had the
worst form and i'm like yo get that [ __ ]
together like this is a little pathetic
i can't have a non-athletic [ __ ] in
this relationship please
and so seeing her say don't get beat up
[ __ ] when she's this skinny and this
tall next to me i was like you know what
try me no you're playing
your place
you literally pick her up and throw it
out
i could toss her across that river
i think you're up next and truth or dare
okay i think i need to dare someone else
actually yeah okay
wait
um
i'll do
i'll do a dare
your mom and say you joined only fans
she went to her phone asap she was like
[ __ ]
honestly yeah knowing how you were
friends i feel like that won't do
anything
right ringside that
hi anna
hey mom
good
um so
you know how i've been like struggling
with like money lately a little bit
yeah
um
i was thinking about like starting and
only fans
okay we've had this conversation before
why do you think i'm recording you
because that's what you
we're do potential material
but but mom i really i really think um
this would be like good quick money you
know what i mean
i don't believe in good quick money
there is no such thing
as good quick money spend 30 years and
go get a job
what about what about feet pictures can
i do that
you don't think really
there's too many weird people in the
you don't world to attract any of them
to you
okay well you talked me out of it thanks
mom
i like your mom i like your mom
i think i've done this this is a problem
no one in my family believes me
with any like any like pranks they do
not believe me wait leaves actually
talked about this before no it wasn't
for me it was someone hacked my my
sister's account on instagram yeah and
so they were putting like like something
on their story like about pictures so i
called my mom like what is gabrielle
doing yeah but it turns out someone
hacked her instagram and now
it's got taken down because someone took
it
truth or dare
leave me alone
what makes you think trouble
yeah
um
truth or dare
the thing is i knew when it got to you i
knew it was going to be me um
[ __ ]
what do you really want to do
do you want do you really want to do a
treat what do you really want to do
there
um i didn't really think of a good one
for either so okay good
because if you said dead then i would
have said truth um
the truth true oh you know what
he's done with the therapy sessions
okay
um oh i have an idea i don't have a
number
what i don't have a number no it's not
oh that's not here i was gonna
who
okay the last girl
you slept with okay
i don't know who it like i i dare you
oh i know her
okay well
i dare you to call her
ask her for 500
i want to see if you can tender swindler
a
but what would the [ __ ] be just say say
that you're like down on rent money and
you need five hundred dollars what
happens when she gives it to you though
what if she don't don't don't take it
what she doesn't know
what if she doesn't answer
i don't oh
i want to see
what happened now i i did i dared him to
call the last girl that
he
slept with
and ask her for 500
and see if she gives it to him
because i wanted to see if he could
tinder swindler [ __ ]
i could drink right
no
we're sexist
you did it to yourself
can i change it the truth no it's too
late like there's not like speakers
didn't you didn't you drink
no no someone drank no one's drink no
one drink
come on go
i've been drinking by choice
well she doesn't answer what well she
doesn't answer
she don't answer a rough life she put a
shot all right
then you text her yeah
all right
you better be quick about a boy cool
thank god you see this long
she's not answering
this
thank god
the question you're calling it
okay
texter
you thought
yeah it was the right number i saw it
beforehand so it's definitely the right
person
what do i say don't be shy let me see
you type that
can
yeah okay or like however it's like in
your words it's like i knew that would
happen
at this moment she knew
she [ __ ] up i'm so happy she didn't
own something
oh
yeah if she calls you back you have to
answer
you know this actually happened the last
time i was here
i knew
i just sent i need 500 pounds they're
microfiber for sure
you're bad
that's a dollar for you no no because
the thing is you already know the type
of towel
i know you know you know
okay yeah i know you
know ending this let me see the delivery
it says
yeah next is on android time
i don't even
my iphone broke
like can you lend it to me you have to
make it clear okay like borrow
i'll pay back never
sorry pro no you're okay the thing is
she might actually say yes that's the
[ __ ] spot oh yeah
okay if she does suddenly get this in a
doctor please he's like the tender
swindler
i'm not that boy i just want to see if
you have it in you
i think you do though [ __ ] boy oh
thank you so much two super chats ninja
watcher for life oh i am going to enjoy
the tinder swindler
yeah 20
sliding camera money
thank you so much guys i'm trying to
raise um
la so you guys when you send a super
chat to me on here i only get like 50 of
the money because my manager takes a cut
and so does youtube
so
so
i'm trying to get to
a thousand dollars and i'm at about like
300 400 ish
so you guys send super chats that way we
can get a second camera
and better lighting and
um what's my saving car oh and a new
table oh my god
okay who's next
me
yes yeah um
[Music]
i feel like you had some spicy ones in
this bowl
did you you should shake it a little bit
just shake it
oh yeah you have to pick truth or dare
or you have to pick a person first
jessica
truth or dare i felt it coming
[ __ ] it let's go with there
i'm crying internally right now
oh this is like a truth
oh we'll pick another ask anyway
that's boring i'm not gonna go through
all these
should i change it to truth
oh
i like this one oh god
that means my life is over first who is
your least favorite ex
who is it
anthony okay
call your least favorite ex to ask them
out
i'll give you
the last i remember is he has a
girlfriend so but he's also trifling
that's the thing
he's trifling so i don't know if i still
have his number blocked or not
but i have to check if he's blocked
this man is a menace just like what's
absolutely in america right now um two
three well in my area it's five hours
behind so it should be about almost six
o'clock right now
okay like in the evening
okay
pray you got some spicy dares i like it
yeah you're creative
thank you thank you
i feel like i take pride in this [ __ ]
i'm not even sure if his number still
works actually i shouldn't i'm not gonna
lie to you i'm not sure she'll tell you
guys with mad well i'm thinking right
now yo what but
you like you saw how quick she replied
right
like after i called her you see after
that message she ain't replied
wait let's see wait she texted you after
you called her straight away what'd she
say she was like um
what did you say one sec
she said um
sorry i can't talk right now what's up
oh okay
okay but what does she say to your
response nothing that's my point so
she's in her head
she's probably showing all her girls
this message right now
yeah i don't care
all right i think i have the number on
i'm not sure if this is the right number
i'm not gonna lie to y'all
it's going towards my phone bill [ __ ]
because i have an international book
that's weird how you guys phone rings
why is yours
they go beep
yeah i think mine's like that
maybe it's android maybe it's just you
please
it's funny because i'm definitely one of
those girls where he would still die for
me type [ __ ] like
he still talks about the fact that he
dated me he used to like flex me to
other people probably the best girl he
could have got that's a fact that is a
fact i got no girl like that
that's a damn shame i'm like that for
all my watching
yeah no i don't care oh [ __ ] he texted
me what are you saying
hey working on a video right now is
everything okay i haven't talked to him
in like a year yeah over a year okay be
like um
be like
just say that
okay and then put free explanation marks
i said answer please
yeah like in your words i'm gonna put on
the the puppy eyes emoji okay
okay now i'm just saying make sure we're
quiet when she does it so he doesn't
hear i'll mute myself every time you all
laugh okay okay
bro he said size and ancestors
okay here it goes
he said okay give me a moment okay
well she is still replying i'm i'm i'm
kind of worried are you hot right now i
am yeah
damn she wouldn't let you fight for
japan
i'm trying to make this phone call fast
because [ __ ] this phone bill going
skyrocket
[Applause]
since we dated and that was in high
school is the dirt done like it's my
idea done i think yeah yeah yeah okay
cool
well yeah if she replies you have to
tell us what she
what's the worst that she's gonna do say
no that you could tell her after it's
not a big deal did she go to the school
no
she lived in the area
she didn't go to the school where's this
woman
really why are you looking like that
she died
no she doesn't
that's not believable
okay just so you all know i'm going to
play up this [ __ ] really funny like i
just hope you all know
i'm sorry i'm going to be like i've just
been really thinking about
okay
how
is he gonna do it now what do you say
all he said was give me a moment so i'm
gonna okay is he gonna call you
i'm gonna say please
no just be like how much is a moment
like
five minutes two minutes three minutes
like i'm in town like i'm in the area
yeah so when you know i think i think he
i think he moved out of the area that he
lives in by now though so i don't know
like he said i don't know [ __ ] about his
life to be honest i just know that he
has this one girlfriend that's ugly i'm
not going to lie to you like really
we could do one while we wait either
truth or dare okay
do you want to pick someone
what's up [ __ ]
i'll do it i'll do truth
oh
i know pearl's a little hard to get with
this type of [ __ ] she's always good with
them so you have to get it back with her
all right uh a time-out break we're all
gonna come in
for the mic
we all gotta we all gotta brainstorm
together guys super chat a truth or dare
don't be wild
not be wild
be insane if you please
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he's calling me
speaker
hello
hello
hey
how have you been
been good how about you
i've been all right
um
i've been thinking a lot lately
and
honestly like i i realized like i just
really miss you and i don't know like
maybe shit's been tough i don't know i
just really miss you and
i feel like we haven't talked in forever
huh
do you think
what
um what kind of made you come to that
conclusion
i don't know i feel like i just looked
back and i feel like we have a lot of
good memories i mean like [ __ ] was tough
to be fair but i feel like we were
really young
and
i don't know things are different now
and i was just really hoping that like
we could meet up sometime soon and just
talk
just talk
about my
[Music]
that's crazy i never thought you'd be
the type to like
you know be tied down to one woman
that's crazy
what about a threesome though
[Music]
why is it n
why is it n
is it because i would find her
unattractive or is it because
what
is it
would i find her unattractive
no are you sure
it wouldn't happen it wouldn't happen
god damn
damn that's a damn shame
yeah sorry i can't really
do anything like that that's not what i
do
okay it sounds like you're outside where
are you going
[Music]
i'm actually gonna go grab some food
that's
been a long four five months of
dieting and [ __ ]
okay so you still wrestling and all that
okay
i mean is your girl giving you that good
head because i could change that
[Music]
no no i can't
well
in that case i'm i'm very proud of you
for being loyal
you kind of have to be boy you don't
have to do anything that you don't want
to
well i didn't want to do that i have to
be and i want to do that i want to
somebody i truly enjoy being with she
got me out of a very dark place that i
was
in my life i got you out of a dark place
did you yeah i did
i i did so much for you and all you did
was break my heart weekly but i'm still
here
actually the thing is like my tony voice
i can't tell from the [ __ ] wrong or
not
i'm sorry i'm just autistic you can't
tell us all right
boy i've been graduated i'm getting my
master's please
[Music]
please okay
i can't
i can't hear you
i just hung up that's it that was enough
of that
trifling
to be fair this kid was actually the
worst to me in high school like the
worst he like leaked my nudes ah yeah
like luckily nobody saw it in time like
i had enough like friends and supporters
that like reported that account asap
which is why like i don't do that kind
of [ __ ] no more super chat i don't know
he like he definitely cheated on me no
doubt about it he just i couldn't get
those i think
i think he was actually down he
definitely was right because you know
what he
still talks about me to this day i know
he does i think he was down he just
didn't he i think he didn't know if you
were serious yeah
like if your girlfriend like you
wouldn't entertain it passed out yeah
yeah yeah he just texted me he put
laughing a move he put a laughing emoji
does do you think he knew that we were
like [ __ ] around yeah we should have
fun
yeah
i don't think you know i feel like he
might have hurt us in the back
no because
like
to be honest he used to be trifling like
for real for real like he he would fold
like any other girl he was dating he
would absolutely come right back to me
and like i never hit him up like i never
was like i want you back or none of that
but i was nice enough to be cordial
between us and he'd come to me about his
like relationships and all that and i'm
like listen dog like
i said
i sent you the super chat that they said
you can decide if you want to ask me
that or not somebody super chatted okay
five dollars from she sent it to you i
texted it to you can i read it tip from
blue pill on blue pill unplugged five
dollars thank you for the super chat
you could
ah man i feel like you ain't doing
nothing but
the question is
what was the most public place you ever
got freaky with an ex
boy with an excellent
[Music]
can everybody answer like
it was in college we i had like a
roommate i shared a room with like you
know sometimes so that's the closest
thing
sometimes what no like i had to like
go to other places because like i didn't
want to do it with my roommate in that
i'm not enough
[Music]
um
you can use code words maybe no i'm just
trying to i'm trying to think of which
one because this was a long time ago so
you don't have to say the name just like
no not the person i'm saying
six different places yeah
um
i would say
yeah either straight maybe this
stairwell like what
wait like when though like during school
hours after school hours was it high
school
no it was just like i had a room i don't
know it would be really late i already
knew she was freaking it'd be like
no it'd be like
like i took the last thing
no i don't i don't care that's i got it
for um there's cranberry juice over
there if you guys work no it was just
like really like late
so it was like
like two three and like like three
i knew nobody was like doing laundry
that lately yeah no one does it yeah or
like in that
i don't know so yeah that was that's
probably the freakiest one of them but
the staff well that's intriguing because
like someone can come from above and
below yeah well that would be like the
way you go to the bar well to be honest
it's more common than you think because
but
i didn't i'm not gonna lie but my one
was in a stairwell my one was like a
like
you get under the stairs at the bottom
no you know you know that's what i do my
friends have done that before that's
giving harry potter because
wait wait what are you gonna say you
know you don't live in america so i
don't know if you don't know and you
lived in like okay but like
we did it in a block like a block like
the hood yeah you're all crazy i've seen
[ __ ] out here kiss on the street so i
mean yeah no no we we
yeah like we do on the streets no no no
no no no no no no wait what
like you know when you like go up this
thing you know you like go upstairs yeah
like and like
obviously
there's those are the stairs isn't it
like there's nothing on the stairs but
anyone can come from upstairs anyone can
come from downstairs you understand he
was in there but at the bottom
like
so like
like an apartment building yeah yeah all
right imagine like this let me explain
it to you cool imagine like the building
like up
this high yeah
you gotta go into the building and you
gotta walk upstairs to get to your floor
or wherever you live yeah yeah
um we was like in between
the top and bottom floor yeah so like
anybody could have just walked past on
top of that like so when you get onto
the top of the block like or wherever it
is
it's an estate it's probably like three
stories or four stories it's like kind
of lots of houses built together and
spain to apartments okay and they're
like stairwells for each apartment yeah
he's saying that he had sex on one of
these on the stairs
was it
i think it might have been summer to be
honest with you but it was like summer
at night
like it wasn't that late like it was
like 11 or 10 or something like that we
went to go
yeah we
okay
seriously oh mommy let me get that
no
it's mad because it wasn't it it wasn't
my idea it wasn't my idea what happened
so you walk up the stairs
of course
what happened what so like you're
walking up the stairs like how does that
one thing lead to having sex which floor
do you decide to [ __ ] on
because you walk to the top like
that
right
like okay there's look i like your lips
you go to the bottom because then like
nobody like that's what i'm thinking no
like we were
for me it's like i'm aware of my
surroundings at all times so it's like
someone comes from the top we're going
to hear the footsteps
we're going to hear that i know exactly
your thoughts and on top of the bottom
you know like with i don't know about
you guys but with our like estates we
have like a fob we need to tap the fob
it's like yeah
cool it's like click the thing to open
the door yeah so it's like bro if we
heard that we're just stopping that's
different i just stepped in so but that
and then the second place was a mall
a more a mall a mall a what ew
i would never [ __ ] them all i see
that [ __ ] dirty as hell no no no you
know like
you know what i'm good like like
the bathroom yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like you know like bro like like have
you guys gone out like we were shopping
we went out shopping together i've heard
a lot of people have done it yeah bro
we're out shopping together
or something yeah exactly i've heard a
lot of changing room stores yeah we
didn't have the change but like but so
we're in the mall cool we were shopping
yeah and
like out in the bathroom
yeah it was about like the bathroom okay
could it have been like a private
bathroom have you i will tell you guys
exactly where it was yeah because
okay tell us details have you guys been
when where time have you guys been to a
green oh let me step out now where
what's green is it by westfield
no no no no no no i've been to westfield
no it's it's like
i don't know
it's like it's cool it's like it's all
green yeah like green is what green man
what grade's the hood okay yeah we're
going to hood um we want to work green
and like but he's got more in there
and bear man i'm saying more because you
guys are american yeah that she didn't
know what i'm saying
um
she was talking that [ __ ] i was talking
that [ __ ] and i was like
like you see once
i don't know about you guys but you see
once i'm there like i'm dead does that
make sense
yeah cool so i was like bro
we have to find somewhere now
we have to find somewhere now it's mad
because
she like the thing is she wasn't too too
much like um on this public thing but
like she knew me she was comfortable
with me you understand so i was like
listen
we're doing this you understand we had
bags we had like wheat because we'd done
shopping we had bags i was like bro
let's go we're going in this in here to
because she was the thing is
she tried to play it off she was like oh
um
because she bought signs she was like oh
i want to try it on i want you to look
at me and see how i look and whatever
obviously i knew i wanted that and she
got changed she was like ah
see how i look and i just took it off
what do you mean see how you look like
oh
we ain't here to see how you look
okay little freaky dicky so yeah that
like that was that that was that i don't
know yeah that was interesting
interesting
how wait how'd you guys feel about
public sex like because
for me it did not comment on that one it
depends
that says a lot
to me it it doesn't um it for me it
matters who it's with you know i sound
like i'm not having random sex outside
with a random like not right yeah like
it's not like a hookup type yeah i ain't
doing that um
i feel like i have to trust you a lot
i'm not an exhibitionist to be fair but
i have done public things per se
but
at the right times okay so like i did
like at my last school like i did it at
um in the bathrooms or like one of the
classrooms as well in the same night
like but it was at night time because it
was during um either midterms or finals
week because they leave the buildings
open during that time so the kids can
study in the library i feel like
nowadays you cannot do that same [ __ ]
because there's too many cameras
everywhere
you think so listen you see mia i think
it's ruined if anything because now
everything's locked down at all times
i'll be so i'll be so honest with you
later i don't give a [ __ ] that you like
all girls on this table listen you see
if that's my girl
or we like we've been there for a while
listen you see if i'm feeling that way
and you're wet but me i'm a spontaneous
person
if you're feeling that way i'm feeling
that way bro we better go find something
that's like a spontaneous thing but
don't get interested that's not every
day that's not like yo let's go find
let's go to it
yeah that's my everyday thing but like
at the same time if you're my girl like
bro
you better know like listen if i grab
you a certain way look at yourself wait
talk to yourself what you bet
okay better be down
all right my bad freaky dicky
okay
but no i wonder what the comments are
for that whole i don't care
what it did there did um the girl
respond did she respond yeah bro she was
like bro like when i said remember i
meant the
damn actually
my ex actually did respond to me what
did he say so like initially um like
after i hung up he sent the laughing
emoji and i said i think the connection
[ __ ] up oh i try to keep going with it
what'd you say
you go first
okay oh wait
sorry
um
lol are you high
the thing is right so i'll tell you why
because she like she knows me she knows
i will never ask her for that say
no i'm just in it i feel like the day's
already done i feel like it has really
done no no come on oh you have to say
i'm so sorry
come on just look in a really like
really tight like i'm struggling
like she's just really tough right now
right already say i want to say i
wouldn't ask you if i didn't i i didn't
really even if i sit i will say don't
get twisted but like i'm gonna say it
and she's gonna know i'm chatting [ __ ]
because she knows i will never ever like
because
she knows i don't know that's what you
gotta say
she knows i'm never gonna do this story
like what's the diet what's the all
right
yeah what did you say um he said oh i
thought you hung up after i said i was
working on my second major to be honest
i didn't even hear that so i guess the
connection really was [ __ ] up he said
you still got that iphone connection i
see and i said i see you still got
android
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
does she know you're on here
um she knows but like she don't know
okay okay
um after he sent that meme he said don't
be calling about no nonsense like that
again that ain't me no more
like unless it's a genuine emergency i'm
good
yeah he was dead seriously i'm actually
happy to see him he was dead seriously
because he used to be [ __ ] terrible
he was horrible bro
cranberry juice oh i think and he was a
gemini
actually i love geminis but they're
scary what yeah i think you said you
didn't like scorpios
i don't dislike scorpios but i'm a
little scared of them stop it i don't
know
what's your star sign oh boy me yeah
what do you think i am gemini mm-hmm
mm-hmm pisces mm-hmm
mm-hmm what
you're kind of closer
no god damn oh my god you guys believe
in that stuff yeah i don't i study
astrology and i read people like a
[ __ ] book crazy
so what have you read
and you know what i'm gonna stand by
that crazy [ __ ]
what'd you read about scorpios then
because you got two here i don't know
about the other two but we're the worst
aren't we no we don't know
because everyone has sex on valentine's
day
yeah at least in america i could say 9.4
of the population is scorpio i believe
really uh yeah in america at least i
don't know about the rest of the world
wow um
but yeah scorpios are just very very
intense beings
but um i i read whole charts that's the
thing so like
you know your sun sign isn't going to
determine everything that you are
obviously there yeah there's different
planets that rule different things like
communication emotion sex relationships
stuff like that
um okay who's next in truth or dare
no i already went did you go oh yeah you
asked i chose this [ __ ] earlier
oh what was the thing oh you you asked
me so it's it's you you're next for
truth wait no wait but you didn't finish
it did you i did steal some of
like the second least problematic you're
probably the least problematic but no
wait what did you know what are you
gonna say
i feel like you already know um
how could it be i don't know just me
said truth or dare
but i don't want to choose anymore yeah
because like we
no we alright anyway wait no you
finished your thought
we know who um
your complicated situations were
yeah
me and you
i think i know too but it's okay um
okay i'm gonna ask a question he would
want me
i'm asking questions
oh
how do i choose
okay true
truth
huh
drinking is still an issue
no
oh actually no i can't do that because
yeah
truth you know what i'm not even gonna
forget him um
don't do it
of chaos
um
besides him
do it dude
besides him is there anyone else you are
speaking to slash
like actually no one
i actually fully believe her i
believe
i can vouch for her i feel like eileen
is not a trifling ass [ __ ]
thank you you know i feel like she she's
a very loyal ass downer what about what
about what about him what about him
is there anything
is there anyone else that he has his eye
on or is talking to listen don't ask me
those questions bro because i i ain't
telling you [ __ ] like i don't want me to
do this oh so you do know something i
don't know anything
i don't know anything
so you know this guy huh the guy
oh
if anyone else has truth or dares put
them in the chat
don't forget them
um
we're probably gonna do like two or
three more and then we're gonna call it
so
i think it's my turn yeah
definitely is your turn dude okay
wait did someone have to demo me or
should i test someone out you have to
ask me the truth or something
characters and everything
i have to sometimes okay
truth or dare
ah jesus
well you got some stuff i feel like
i'm gonna go with truth just because i
feel like my dad was enough jessica can
i read you this comment yeah damn she
must have given him that good sex if he
answered it after not hearing from her
in a year
it's actually been more than a year i
haven't i haven't talked to him since
like 2019.
i haven't talked to him since like 2019
yeah
yeah it is it's been a long time
safe to say
yeah
like three years what's your truth or
not okay what is the worst date that
you've been on the worst date i've been
on
time
[Music]
i haven't really been on like bad dates
before to be honest i feel like i have a
very um personable personality so i
usually get along with most people yeah
but i will say this was like one of my
first boyfriends ever yeah i was like 15
at the time i was dating like a senior
in high school but what's the age
difference those are the worst
that's all right so the thing is um the
age range for each grade is like
different
i'm the oldest for my grade typically
yeah i'm on the older side so i'm old
enough to be a great above yeah okay um
so at the time as a freshman which is
the first year of high school i'm sorry
so you're a libra i am i knew it okay
you got it [ __ ] you've got me
um he was actually a senior at the time
but he was young enough to be a junior
and i was old enough to be a sophomore
so that's right in the middle like
you're a freshman so it's like i don't
know like 16 i don't know seven no 14 to
15. okay 14 15 and you're probably 15.
yeah i was 15 because he was like 17
maybe yeah turning 18 and it was like in
december so
um
i remember this is like my first real
date ever like my family low-key didn't
know i was out because they didn't allow
me to date at this time
but um he took me out to like this super
cute restaurant like it was like a
little after um christmas i would say
because i had that christmas money you
know like your family started yeah they
started giving you that the bills i was
like yeah i keep it coming yeah
yeah and um he took me out to this nice
little italian restaurant i love italian
food i'm a weakling for pasta and i
remember at the end of the day he was
like is it okay if you
something something
and
slay the reigns i don't know what the
[ __ ] he said but i was very confused and
i was like what and he's like you cover
the bill and i'll cover the tip and i
was like this is like my first real day
ever and you want me to cover this and
i'm 15 years old [ __ ] i will beat your
ass
i was so pissed off i was like what the
[ __ ] this is my first real date out of
the restaurant and i got my christmas
money and you want me to spend my
christmas money on this date i'm pissed
like
i was pissed off since that day so i
never let nobody treat me like that
again unless i know i got it like that
and i'll be like hey like don't worry
i'll cover this date yeah you know yeah
but so he didn't play
i was expecting like
his ex-girlfriend yeah
his ex-girlfriend hit me up talking
about some like we're all expecting some
kind of spicy stuff i have a lot of
spicy stories about my first date truth
or dare okay so who didn't want to do
she respond yet
this broke-ass [ __ ] okay
actually
eileen oh no
truth or dare
i'm gonna trip
i'm not doing any more dares okay you
can't back out of this question
oh
[ __ ] okay this is amazing i mean she's
been thinking about this i know i [ __ ]
up she knew i was gonna choose you
should have chosen are you in love
i wouldn't i would i don't know yet
i don't know yet i don't know yet
um it's
too early to say i feel like if you
don't know then it's a no i think it's
too early don't know now you know
exactly like
so what do you need to be in love
what do you need commitment from him
yeah that's the answer
i know what's he doing
huh
what's up or is it you
let's change it up what is the okay
you can do it you can do one back to me
okay
oh no i didn't i've seen it i need some
time off i'm turning red are you still
stuck on your ex
oh no
no wait i don't expect you to to be
honest nah [ __ ] that no no i like i
wasn't for a while like like the last
time but now i'm like this man is crazy
oh my god sorry i should not mance is
losing his damn mind but no i'm like a
lot i don't know if you've noticed but
i'm like a lot happier now yeah i know i
definitely don't know
i definitely noticed that and you've i
think you've been more like outgoing
with like hanging out with us and
everything yeah and like even more bold
on the court like yeah you know i know
that's what i was saying when i first
got here i like didn't do anything or
talk to anyone yeah like that's when you
know that person was not it for you you
could do another though that was that
was a rough one for the truth or dare
he's not watching this
if he's watching it he won't mind his
goddamn business he's literally just
calling he's off work so i'm hoping he
didn't click on the link
um i have to marinate a little bit on
this one okay you can go first
let me think real hard about it okay
this one has to be what about the
question she asked you for now the
question for that i'm gonna ask her okay
so you can
go have you been in a lot of talking
stages
i've been in a lot of talking stages
um
i was in one for a very long time i
would say that's like
how long was it
um
oh man if it exceeded three months i'm
gonna be [ __ ] myself i'm gonna tell
you that right now
no it was a really long it was it was
like it was um
i always say because it's kind of
it's kind of like when i talk about this
situation i don't really like going into
a lot of detail because it's like
it's kind of like honestly embarrassing
yeah
but no i was in a talking stage for like
years with the guy lost my virginity too
yeah like literally years years yeah
that's rough hold on have you met this
person like or was it like just talking
oh no no we were hooked it was like
everything like yeah but like no one
wanted how old was he that's that kind
of thing um i was 19. he was
you were talking for years i don't know
i was 20 i think when i lost and what
was years like when did you stop talking
um i think i stopped when i was 22. so
20 to 22. so that was two years and what
was those conversations like did you go
out did you did you go on dates no i was
like
this guy like actually like broke my
heart i didn't date like literally i
moved cities to get away from this guy
because i was like i swear to god i did
because i was like i was like
i don't know i don't think i could i
wanted to it's kind of embarrassing um i
wanted to wait till i was like married
to like have sex you know like i really
wanted to that's not embarrassing no no
no no i wasn't no no no this is the
embarrassing part is
um and
like
yeah i don't know and so when i didn't
when i did it i didn't really realize
how attached i was gonna get and i was
like very very attached so yeah yeah for
like
like two maybe three two three years um
but then i decided because i had a
better job in chicago but i took a
shittier job in milwaukee because i just
felt like i didn't have the self-control
to like not because i knew he still you
know what i mean yeah yeah so then i
moved to milwaukee and then i stopped
that was like when i stopped drinking
and i stopped like talking to him and
then i literally like i didn't sleep
with anyone for two years and that nuts
yeah dedication and then and then i met
my last boyfriend and i'm here so
but yeah that was the i'll sometimes
i'll say it was like the guy i was with
in college or whatever because it's like
i don't feel like what else do you call
that yeah yeah i got you i get you
that's not embarrassing though
i genuinely feel like i wasn't i was
embarrassed listen love
genuinely makes you dumb yeah i hate to
say it like but it's true like
psychological it does it does make you
lose sight of things that you follow i
just said well i think i was just really
naive to be honest because
i like i remember thinking like i never
looked through this man like i just
really thought i was the only one like i
don't know why
what was your lot's head
it's bad to think that like if you're
like it's just your first time my head
well my head was just like it's too
painful to leave so i don't like want to
you know what i mean because i was just
god that's when it hurts yeah and so
that's why i was like okay i need to
like put myself in a situation where
when i'm because it would be like i
would stop for a little bit and then
like it would just be like one you know
one day i'd like miss him and like it's
too easy because he's right you know
what i mean i get that
yeah and i think it was like a lack of
like you know self-respect when it comes
to love it's like the comfort and
familiarity that we get out of it that
makes us want to stay yeah you know it's
like this person has already seen me
through so and so and so yeah i don't
want to have to go over like what's my
favorite color with a new person all
over again no it was not it was not wise
honestly
how old is everyone at the table
25 23 25 23 25 4 20 24 20
you're 20 yeah i get that
you're 20 yeah you're getting like
pretty mature you know a lot of people
say that i think i dated someone that
was a lot older than me 10 years old
i think also like the accident probably
throws me off also
what do you guys think
like so when you guys say
love
what is that
um
it's a sticky one
yeah yeah we tend to mistake infatuation
for love very often
um but i feel like we're like as you get
older you're able to distinguish the
difference between those you know for a
fact so now that you guys are older what
is the distinguishing facts
well i think i think love is when you
make a commitment bear in mind she
hasn't answered that question yet just
saying
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
again sorry um what question if you're
in like are you in love i said i don't
know
i feel like that's not that's not an
awesome message i feel like
like
like i can't say yes or no i mean like
we're still like getting to know each
other
for that look sorry let me be quiet
sorry carry on no go ahead we're gonna i
just said for that long for that long
i mean it's been a while
i think like initially when we both
entered this like we weren't thinking
like anything
honestly
and then like
i don't know like we've like learned to
like enjoy each other's company
and now
you will learn to love him
so would you want to have that you will
learn to love him yes um
i mean
i don't know i don't
like me personally i don't think of
like love or whatever like too lightly
or like being committed to someone too
lightly because like i know like how
hard that is
um so
like you know i think very carefully
through my actions and my thought so i
don't
sorry
[Music]
so that's what i'm saying like i don't
know yet
if i am or i'm not okay
okay like it's a real answer i'm not
just trying to be like yeah get you
hungry halfway
i think love's a choice
are you scared
um
i feel like the mosaics
i feel like the museums you know maybe a
little bit but it's just i think it was
just more like because i don't know what
i'm gonna be doing after this year okay
like you know i
do want to extend my visa to stay here
longer
and like but i may also want to go and
like play pro
volleyball
and i don't know where i'm gonna be at
and like he doesn't know where he's
gonna be at and like it's just you know
that's why i'm not you go down i'm not
letting myself get in too deep before i
make that decision you've got a typical
athlete
relationship like yeah i mean i just i
just know how to like be able to control
my emotions after like everything i've
been through so
is that a good thing i think that's
pretty great because why would why would
i let
myself get in too deep if i'm no if i
know i'm gonna go somewhere else or if i
don't know what i'm gonna do but
wouldn't you say wouldn't you
beg that like
if if it's love if it really is love
then
it's worth it
but love doesn't have to be everything
that sometimes loves not enough like
sometimes that you've got other goals
and stuff that you have in your life
that i say love is never enough it's
always a choice yeah and if i i feel
like if i have my own aspirations that i
want to get done exactly like i'm not
going to let one person change that if i
really want that but the thing is that i
don't know exactly what i want yet so
you know what what
random but
i like the fact that you said that
because you know a lot of people don't
realize don't um a lot of females and
males sorry like the people
um
don't realize that
that what you just said um they don't
actually fully know
what they want yet that's what i'm
saying or even who they are yeah
i'm just like
i just know that if
there's something that i want to do and
i let someone change what i want to do
then i'm just going to resent them and i
don't want that to happen because i like
you know i love all the people that i
meet or whatever and like i think i've
just learned that from
relationships through like family and
friends and like what they regret the
most is not doing what they wanted when
they were younger at the end of the day
i don't want to be that person at the
end of the day someone who truly cares
about you and supports you is going to
support your actions and what you want
the most out of life you know so if
somebody's going to change that
then they don't fully love you for who
you are i genuinely feel that i think
this comes down to
when you cut when you think about love
slash a relationship
what are you looking for
but do you think love is just love or do
you think love is like a choice i think
love is a choice but it's become more so
like an exchange like i feel like when
you go online tinder people have to kind
of like sell themselves to market
themselves like yeah oh like i'm going
to be athletic with sports take care of
myself then someone else is going to see
that i'm like yeah i can i choose to
love someone that does those things yeah
it's not like i don't know i think it's
a choice like i think it's like like
okay when i think of love i think of my
mom
like
i don't know cooking for my dad
and it's like little stuff like that
that's like a choice
the little things that you constantly do
consistently consciously
and subconsciously especially
consciously and consistently
and it's just like doing those little
things for that other person i feel like
it doesn't take something away from me
but it takes like the effort for you to
do that for them i don't think it takes
anything away from you i feel like it
gives you something yeah yeah because
you know you're happy giving that person
that you love something exactly like
that gives you happiness is that yeah
you don't need anything in return at
that moment
but [ __ ]
you're deep here i love you a lot
because i i know what it was like to be
stuck in a relationship where like i
definitely didn't get the love that i
deserved back and i was doing laundry
for that [ __ ] yeah
i love you to do live
doing my own life oh my god i used to
like cook i used to clean all the oh my
god i used to do like too much
when you find yourself doing housewife
work right yeah you know you're right
what you guys what's your guys idea of
too much because like i just like
yeah what you guys have there's no such
thing as too much as long as i'm getting
the same back in return but it's like
just noticing that like wow i've never
done this for someone else before like
my siblings don't get this kind of you
know privilege
i'm gonna be like girl you're gonna
learn how to do laundry today like you
know that with your siblings if you have
siblings like you pull them a drink like
yeah i've got more than you like with
like someone you love like oh like i'll
give them a bit more like you can have
like the biggest i ain't been like that
i haven't been like that like
my siblings like bro like if i
have this yeah i'm like bro i got like
one older brother
um one little sister one little brother
yo brother or brother
anyone you want yeah anyone you want
like and my thing is like a dad
a mom
my thing is like bro like that's my
siblings like i love them i love them my
siblings like because for me like my
brothers uh he's 27. like
i'm 22. so we're kind of close yeah and
it's like bro like if you're struggling
but i've got you don't even don't even
even don't
worry yeah like you're my brother you
understand like same thing with my
little sister like with my little sister
for instance yeah i'm gonna give you a
little story my little sister got
my little sister got excluded from
school yeah
so you guys see this from school because
she punched some girl in her face
my little sister got into a fight
recently too so i would hear this yeah
so she like
she punched some girl on her face yeah
and i was like what yeah my like my
sister grabbed that she grabbed her by
her neck and she punched her and i was
like bro like bear in mind like
all my siblings like we like don't [ __ ]
with us type of thing like if you piss
us off like it's
it's ropes yeah cool and she's like the
girls pissed her off and she punched her
um and i was like to a bro like
i've gone to her and i'd be like bro
like
out of love bear in mind because it's
what we're talking about
i've gone to my like i've spoken to my
mom i've been like cool what's happened
spoke to my mom then i spoke to my
sister to see if she's going to tell me
the truth she told me the truth
and i was like bro
why did you do that and then my because
my sister knows like i love her like we
had actually come back my sister was 16.
we had a actual conversation i was like
bro like you don't go punching people
bro like bear in mind you
like yeah i understand that you are mad
but understand that when you hit my age
you have there's consequences you
understand you don't you can't just hit
a hit [ __ ] and expect
oh i'm gonna get excluded for two months
no bro you're 20 like if you're my age
of 22 bro you go in jail yeah that's
assault
how do you like talk to her about it
i feel like that's good that you talked
about it it's a serious offense yeah but
like to me like what i'm saying though
like it's not even about me talking to
talking to her but it's like it's like
bro that's love yeah like for me that
for me that that's like how you like how
you're showing up to your sister that's
how i'm showing up just like like i love
my siblings like obviously but like i
think as like growing up and they're
really close to your age like my sister
like basically felt like a twin because
we were a similar age we used to get
catty over small things like
that competitive sibling like oh my god
like i noticed if you love someone it's
a bit different like those competitive
things like you would care about like
with your sibling like oh like i get
more cake or those kind of stupid things
like with the person you love you're
like oh i want to give them more cake
i want them to have more than me my
older brother is in prison yeah okay
like
he calls me like oh what you have you
got this much money for me it's like bro
like like if i got it hold it you
understand it's not even a thing like
just bro that's you yeah amazon
it's like
for me it's like bro like that's love
for me it's just love like i ain't got a
question why you need it or is that bro
just hold what you need bro
don't even like in a relationship you
know just like it's different to how
like your relationship it was a sibling
when you're in love with yours like you
love your siblings but you're in love
with someone something's a bit different
it is
and that's what like i mean by like
going like the extra math like obviously
you do that for your sibling but in the
way you do like i love it's a bit
different no no because it's love love
is love i think i think
stop
it no
family members versus someone you're in
love with
okay okay let me ask you guys a question
let me ask you guys a question thank you
um
he's your boyfriend yeah and someone
his name
um
cool um
your parents don't like him okay your
sister don't like him your brother don't
like him okay are you still going out
with him
um
uh i think that depends on the reasons
why my family and my brother my brother
i have an older brother
and why they don't like him because i
would say like your family does have a
lot more insight you know than you think
that you would like to think at least
and like i didn't realize this until
like i was like past my college years
actually because like that was when like
my family actually told me
like oh like i don't like this person
because of this and this and like i feel
like because they're family like they
know they may or may not i feel like
they do know like yeah deep down as soon
as they meet
they
they know what is sketchy and they know
what is not especially like i would say
like through
my parents like experiences like they
would know what is right for me or not
and like i would say if it's valid
i would believe like what would what
would their reasons be do you have an
example
um
he's disrespectful disrespectful towards
my family
absolutely not let me give an example
here
but what if he's not really
disrespectful like what if you don't
feel like i'll give you an example
actually
because this really happened cool so i
was of my girlfriend obviously okay
brought to my mom's house my mum was all
talking about uh she's disrespectful in
my head looks like bro this is the most
sweetest girl i've ever met in my life
what do you mean she's disrespectful
like and the thing is when she comes in
i see how she interacts with my mum yeah
i see how my mom interacts with her and
it's like bro she hasn't done anything
wrong so it's like for me it's like bro
it's not between it's not the race
between me and my girl it's not between
me my girl my mom my sister my sister my
brother like bro we ain't it's not
between all of us it's just between me
and the girl so it's like at that point
it's like it's my happiness it's not
about
how you guys feel but what did she do to
make them think that you were that she
was being disrespectful towards you or
your family or whatever that's my
question
so there was a reason
there was a reason it wasn't really her
fault it was kind of my fault but it was
like how can you blame her like okay so
what was it you have to be specific to
me
don't be shocked you told me you told me
and give me an example so i'm waiting
for you i think your family watching
this
definitely okay then you got nothing to
worry about um
i've brought us in my mom's house yes
and she's my mom whatever they get along
wherever
but like
when we're um
together alone
we're very loud
okay well you said that wasn't okay you
already said that something was trifling
i feel like this is the most trifling
thing you've ever done
no because that's in a relationship like
like you like you and the girl were
really loud together like you guys were
like bickering no no like what were you
guys laughing oh just doing things yes
okay okay
okay i'm sorry cool and like in your
family's house oh man listen listen
listen to this
that's bold
that's disrespectful wait no because
like
was it at your family's house though
yeah but you're you're you're normal and
my normal might be two different normals
you understand it might be but also like
i think no matter what if you doing [ __ ]
in your family's house oh [ __ ] i'm so
sorry
god damn it i was hoping i wouldn't be
the [ __ ] to do it and i did it i think
it's officially tasted drunk
just a little bit just a little just you
don't mind your goddamn video
guys um
in my opinion like i feel like
i mean it's fun to like
it's fine i feel like it's fine to like
you know have sex in your parents house
but like you know also like mind your
environment i think just being discreet
about it like
like like okay now now let me explain to
you why it was my fault like
um
cool you know like i don't i don't even
know if i can like right here
in the bottom of the mic
thank you for like oh yes no no problem
there you go okay okay
that was kind of a workout
that was heavy do you try my apologies
y'all you're good you're gonna do it let
me explain to you why it was um i'm
usually not the [ __ ] that this goes for
today you know my fault oh
my fault because like you know when you
you know when you're cool you know
you're having sex so
like
like i don't know
if you guys are girls you're not gonna
get but like there's a certain level we
will give a girl you understand like
it translates to how much they care
about you so if they're still wearing
like i know that sounds weird okay yeah
like if they're still wearing like their
sh they're not their shoes but like
their socks
they're boxers and they just pull their
dick out through the boxers
and they put if they're still wearing
their shirt
that's that that's that shows you how
much they care about you if they're
fully naked then they are fully
vulnerable with you mm-hmm i [ __ ] you
not mm-hmm this feels psychological
right now
bro i've been studying psychology for
years since middle school so that means
like since i was like 14 i know this
[ __ ] every man has something my thing is
i won't take off my socks i ain't taking
off my socks bro
bro
if i don't like you like my socks ain't
coming off your feet like really
ugly wait okay wait can you finish your
story but how it was your fault though
yeah
um
like you know cool as i said like you
know when you're [ __ ] like you
oh you don't know because you're not
you're not guys that but that you can
give a girl
i don't even know how to explain it like
you can give a girl like
all of what you have
or not like you can like because
and i'm not talking like you can put
hundreds all in or not no like no like
how do i explain it like we can like
cool there's a certain dick we will give
you depending on how we view you you
understand if i don't think you're like
bro i'm just trying to bust my night and
i'm out you understand certain girls but
other girls like if it's your girl and
you're gonna stay and cuddle with them
and talk to them about some [ __ ] this
one's in and like
depending on where you're going like
i'm giving you the 10 10. yeah you
understand so you're giving 100 of what
you could like you're doing 100 percent
yeah yeah that way yeah but that girl
yeah and that's why she was like and
that's why she was loud but also like
okay but
this is so much detail for like okay
i honestly forgot the original no no
that's not sad like like
i don't think there's a good reason to
be allowed at your parents house just
because
just just because you like her like how
about is is it's like you you allowed
your mom just happened to come in the
house
but you knew that no but you knew that
she was gonna come home for one period
no you maybe you guys knew the way my
house works like bro does your mama pay
for the rat
i mean i don't live no no it's a yes or
no question i don't live with my mom
okay anymore anymore
like all right no if i especially don't
live with my parents no more i'm not
going to bring a [ __ ] home or a [ __ ]
home point-blank period no
because that's disrespectful to them
like if they're going to be gone for a
whole week
maybe i'll be bold enough but maybe
you're like boyfriend or girlfriend
yeah like no matter what i have to
respect my parents at baseball you know
like that is their house their parents
at the end of the day this is how i see
things yeah if you're my girl
yeah
that's my mom
my mom says my mom said no let me let me
explain to you my mom says to you my mom
says to me
no one says me i don't like that girl
that girl's one two three four five okay
okay explain why yeah if my mom can't
articulate that then i'm just like your
[ __ ] but let's say she did
articulate why
she didn't like you guess what that's
still my girl mum and i like her
whatever you don't like i feel that way
shall i tell you why but you know
sometimes she'll tell you why you have
to like back up what you feel bro you
want to be happy
um
i think the reason why i don't
understand is because my parents have
really good intuition you know like my
dad he can spot a [ __ ] [ __ ] from a
mile away well that's it that's what i'm
saying like it just depends what happens
i think sometimes your friends and
family can see stuff you don't because
you're in fact yeah
love is a powerful drug especially if
you're so in love it just literally
blinds you from all the righteousness
maybe trust your parents or not like if
you know they've got good intuition
they can always tell yeah if you have a
tendency to rebel against your parents
you're definitely not going to listen to
them you know but be like i've always
been a good girl i've always listened
we're going to do the last question last
question okay eileen go ahead
oh this is going to be a little spicy i
really hope you don't okay it doesn't
matter
she's been thinking about this for a
minute um
say if
your ex
okay your most recent one okay um
had been
you know you guys have been broken up
for a little bit
and then the
other person never happened do you think
if he went up to you right now would you
take him back oh god no yeah really no
but i mean like being the person that
you were before even if you the person
you were before would you take them back
comparing to what you were now
the person oh like when like when i was
in college um more like um before you
found out like the last thing that he
did to you before you found out he was
trying
before the last thing that happened um
would i have taken him back
i probably
if that didn't happen
i don't know if i if i did i probably
would have had to see that he actually
like put in the work that he told me he
did yeah
because that's kind of where i was at
when i was like reconsidering it i was
like you said you made these you know
and he made it happen yeah so like let's
see and then and there was that one big
big big that one yeah that that thing
that happened that they proved to me
that it did not he did not in fact
change um
so but that was my fault like i
shouldn't get with a guy expecting them
to change it's my own fault so so that's
what i
so i would say there's nothing wrong
with trust me i would say i would say i
would have probably tried but i probably
would have seen the same thing like in
the end you would have just ended up
where you are now yeah i would say so
too yeah
i probably i i'm if someone gives me a
good apology i'm like yeah i'm kind of a
sucker for it no me too i fully
understand because like as soon as
somebody gives me a proper apology and
takes full responsibility yeah yeah like
okay i see you you know what you did
wrong so i can trust that you won't [ __ ]
up again yes yeah but you know i would
say that i love the person that you've
grown to be after him
and then you know now you've like fully
wandered with us i feel like that we've
kind of gotten to know you i don't know
no we're like friends yeah
i always say i have no friends and i'm
like i actually do
i love your family too
okay well that was a fun way to end the
show um
so before we end tell them where they
can find you put in your instagrams
youtube whatever you want to put
at tiana pirates stanley is my instagram
um i'mma get i got two um if you need a
sports massage it's at
blue therapy
blue
therapy um if you want to
scrimmage and play basketball dennis
then it's the doghouse
t-h-e-t-h-e by the e is a three
g-h-e dog house
h
h
h you guys say eight right yeah t h
three and then dog house
um i instagram uh
yeah and that's that's my scrimmage and
so anyone that needs a massage can come
get a massage
he's getting a little freaky
yeah there's not happy ending
it's professional it's professional it's
not happy endings but um
there you go there you go um
yeah so
blue therapy
b-o-u-u therapy um the dog house th free
dog house if them if that makes sense to
you guys but yeah that's my instagrams
all right um jessica delic on tick tock
i don't got no other
you know social media but jessica delic
c-h-e-s-k-a
d-e-l-i-c already know
[Music]
um
ali e-i-l-e-e-n-s-h-i-32
on instagram and venmo if you would like
to send me some money
helpful [ __ ] out masters is very
expensive okay
okay guys do not forget to subscribe to
the channel and bring that notification
bell while you're at it y'all some money
the
the my paypal and um app is in the
description
paypal and cash app is in the
description and just you know where the
money is going right now i don't even
take you guys money i just reinvest it
into this equipment so new table okay
new table
new cameras
new table more people yeah and more mics
and more mics
cameras lighting also another way you
can support okay
the cooking with chris get yourself a
meal plan okay
and i was